we've already talked about the games
that have come out this year yeah also
let's talk about the games that are yet
to come out this year yeah they're
coming at in the future I have this in
some sort of a chronological list I
probably haven't covered everything
apologies in advance internet but let's
get right to at first things first no
man's sky at August ninth y'all excited
y'all ready for this do did it yeah you
excited yeah i'm i'm cautiously excited
well it looks really ambitious I'm
worried if that's gonna be a detriment
like with such a massive universe I'm
worried that it's sacrificing substance
in the process I hope they prove me
wrong cuz I'm really excited to play it
curious yeah I think I echo those stuck
those worries i guess what about you
Peter I'm curious but I don't have high
hopes okay and I don't think that's
worried i think the game is not going to
be as great as everyone thinks really
okay i'm usually I'm really excited like
the thing that I enjoy from open-world
games more than editing is exploring so
you don't need that much you know I'm my
requirement of substance isn't as high I
don't think like I just enjoyed faffing
about like I played well of warcraft 4
years and yeah okay that's good point
and just like rambled but yeah I guess
we'll see we'll see very soon August
ninth Gears of War for is that later
that month what do you think Peter I I
really like the first gears of war and
kind of fell off I went back to play
judgment and thought okay but this is
just kind of more gears of war like a
little bit of like here's a mole in
between Yeah right [ __ ] that's good but
I want to see what they can do right
like it seems to be like the time this
will make or break here's war if this
doesn't if it doesn't work there's not
any gears five and eventually they know
that so like they've really have to put
a lot into it so I'm hoping there is
that urgency and pans out I'm a huge fan
I love the first the second game I'd or
third game I thought was really good as
well judgment was the one that kind of
wrote out for me a little bit short and
i gotta say like I really want this game
to be great but nothing I've seen any of
the previews has made me particularly
confident yeah and even playing the
multiplayer beta like I think they did
the really good job of like making a
Gears of War to stop multiplayer beta
but I guess I just don't want to fake
gears war 2 multiplayer anymore yeah
that's just it i mean it just it
this series seems that you can always
predict it's going to be more of what
what it always has been you can do that
for a lot of series but especially
something like Halo and Gears of War or
like yeah I feel like both those series
I'm kind of ambivalent too because it's
like I've kind of been there done that
yeah maybe i'm missing the details but
maybe there's no law against the likes
it somewhere but yeah not for not for us
necessarily what you think like I played
it at e3 I'm actually I think a little
more excited than I was okay right it
seems like it's kind of able to get out
of its own way when it needs to it was a
very like measured campaign mission I
saw not the demo at e3 I played
something different right I'm it's like
this xbox media showcase and it was
really it took its time and developing
it like an atmosphere and tone if I like
more like there was horror overtones now
right and I like I actually liked the
characters um JD phoenix JP i don't
remember his first name it's marcus
fenix likes his son yeah maybe junior do
you maybe they can pull something out of
that I don't know I'm a little more
excited than it was two months ago
alright but yeah be the best father-son
relationship god of war Oh Garza for a
new thing Gio w or geo w and speaking of
father-son relationships sure why not
the Last Guardian it has a release date
now I guess September it yes they just
rocked october twenty third is that what
it is yeah like two days ago okay so
it's little later near actually yeah
what do we think about that i mean it's
such an unknown quantity i feel like
it's unknown but waiters pass work kind
of speaks for itself i think when you
cut when you we're trying to figure out
what to expect from this game like it's
going to be very atmospheric it's going
to be very subtle cues that communicate
what most games try to communicate
through overt you know dialogue or
stuffing you know i just i think that
this game will be special but whether or
not it's going to be amazing and worth
the 10 11 years we've waited for it
right that i really can't say it's
really hard to know yes i jump the gun
there that's coming out October 25th so
that's right look back to sep tember
time and Final Fantasy 15 September 30th
yeah there you go why are you very
worried about that kid it's everyone
I've talked to you about this seems to
be like super warriors the first two
demos they put out it was kind of
encouraging is it's like okay cool we're
getting a slice of this game we've been
waiting for and it's competent it's
doing new things and it's for the most
part of succeeding at them
but then they showed that and I hate to
just like take one bad it you know exam
ride call the game out but the e3 demo
was awful there's there's no getting
around that like not even just the way
that that the person playing the demo
performed it just looked like a really
poorly constructed boss battle yeah and
then the VR thing they showed and then
everything when I've heard is played it
just sounds like it's a joke and I worry
that this game is sort of trying to do
too much or maybe trying to do too much
and just relying on spectacle or I sort
of be its main selling point because you
know we we know how combat kind of works
we kind of know the characters are but
there isn't a great sense of how the
game how it all ties together and I
think that is going to be the bigger
thing and if the details there in aren't
good it's probably gonna be kind of
problematic but I hope it's great I
gotta love Final Fantasy the waiting for
this game for a long time and Tabata is
a nice guy who seems to know what he's
doing we just have to wait and see yeah
okay let's shift from the world JRPGs to
I guess the Big Easy mafia 3 October 7th
y'all looking forward to this I've been
very interested in what they're doing it
seems like a unique setting unique
character and what do you think like I
really like period pieces and games I
remember like LA noir despite all its
faults i'm still like want to play that
game just for the kind of setting it
created that like The Saboteur yeah I
also like to her okay I like that as
well I'd like to I'd like to Sasson
screed before it got pretty you know
wrote but that's what I mainly attracted
mafia 3 and it sounds like it too cool
character the main one uh it sounds like
it's dealing with some pretty heavy
issues see how they actually execute on
those we'll see but yeah I'm excited for
that battlefield one we talked a bit
about it already today October 21st any
interest in here while I know they're
interested my gate i'm super-interested
I'm someone who I don't really care
about battlefield is the series and doom
is like the fur Dumon titanfall the only
first-person shooters I've actually
really enjoyed for a long time but
watching these guys play battlefield
once a day like the setting looks right
the weapons the the vehicles all that
looks so good I am very excited to play
it actually let's talk about time phone
as well because that's a pretty quickly
after october twenty eighth yeah
following week
campaign I know who knew yeah well i
guess it was what everyone was asking
for for the longest time excited about
it definitely there you go me too I mean
I like mex it's it's a fun shooting game
otherwise and there's a lot of great
mobility like it's hard not to love that
game yeah first one especially it was
like the first game that started off
that big wave of yo let's make
first-person shooters interesting again
that movement we've kind of had a lot of
it they have riches in terms of that for
the past two years and being to see what
they can do to sort of I guess reaffirm
their position as the the head honchos
with that stuff yeah I played a couple
matches at e3 is really fun so the the
Titans themselves like superheroes now
there's I on who is it's all those
attacks are laser attacks right to tax
scorch flames so it's really cool like
Vince Zampella was saying that robot
wars yeah they're saying there's a big
lake tilda coming out to go back to
Street Fighter they so there's a big
fighting game influence on it you know
like you start to learn sorry hear me
out like Dark Souls I don't want to hear
I ok ok like Vince up a delivery said
the same thing on our game like on
everything yeah every document these
preps to talk about this game this one's
like sub-zero this guy's like noob
saibot here I Mike camera ready time to
move on you coming out excited come here
October 28 I mean it's really weird cuz
it's wedged in between the other two
it's gonna be mental battle field twenty
first planetfall to 28th November fourth
call of duty infinite warfare look
forward to that at all kinda I love I
like space I like space battle wait I
always like personal space personal
space I do need some personal space I
freaked out at a the other day oh yeah
yeah that'll happen yeah they make it
made a game about that called space
invaders classic wow wow good good yeah
that's good like you have to credit my
friend he actually said that elbow get
out of here friend joke he doesn't he
doesn't read her why she was fun though
who was it a lot of worth know from back
home okay you don't need no shadow Nico
I news all what up your
eco yeah he was e the star of grand
theft auto four no okay shame Italian
yeah all right Peter hi call duty in for
warfare yeah I like whole dude campaigns
I like space its rapid right yeah yeah
yeah stick it on the box infinity ward I
mean I'm super like down on look at
these guys getting rolled over by a
[ __ ] a helicopter so dumb and I'm
super like not interested in the past
couple of called it d game so David find
it just been known quantities there's
something about this I liked what they
showed at e3 because it was them saying
hey guess what combat is fundamentally
changed because we're going to be using
space in interesting ways and I like the
jetpack and the hook and all that stuff
so I am I'm sort of hoping this will be
an interesting new take on the formula
they certainly seem to be trying to do
it and I think it's difficult for them
to change it up too much because they
risk alienating a lot of people who are
two super into call of duty every single
year so we'll have to see Dishonored 2
who likes it yeah all right two hands up
that's coming at November 11th right
after called a tease a lot of good games
coming act and yeah i mean this game has
been a long time coming it looks
beautiful what we saw III yeah yeah the
actual like moment to moment gameplay
between now there's two characters I've
Corvo and Emily yeah I believe Emily
being the one you like rescued the first
games was pretty bad as you get to
player but her she also has a very
different style to her gameplay instead
of it blinking at the tendrils right
that she's shooting out like a grappling
hook kind of thing Jackie Estacado in
the darkness tendrils yes uh yeah they
also showed a bunch these new powers it
looks like it's gonna be more of this
honored one which is I'm not I'm not
disappointed in knowing like arcane
studio well I mean not knowing that I
don't know them well they have like two
games I don't know any names I don't
know but a lot a lot of people who've
made a lot of great oh yes has done
their roots go back to like the system
shock days from like Looking Glass
Studios yes good stuff I'm looking
forward to how like the experimentation
is gonna play out with the different
powers and everything yeah another game
coming out from a studio that we may or
may not know I don't know I'm
running out of segues here at four days
after that the watchdog's dose uh what
do you think of watch dogs do I was very
interested when they first showed it off
I was kind of like cautiously optimistic
and talking to the guys at e3 I'm a
little bit less I was interested in them
really like tackling the whole East Bay
West Bay kind of thing well and then
yeah and then it sounds like oh yeah
some of our designers live there for
like a year yeah Wow like I it just
seems like if you're gonna take an
african-american protagonist and throw
them into San Francisco's like crazy you
know white gentrification world you
really need to jump into that I mean
it's something like I live in Oakland
and it's like that's like the constant
like that's what people are talking
about ya know what I mean so it's it's
from talking to them it seems like they
are probably going to delicately
acknowledge and not jump too far into
ish which I'm a little bit disappointed
about but apart from that i'm very
interested in playing this game in a way
in terms of like just pure gameplay the
whole like hacking any car hacking a lot
of stuff i like the idea of doing that
the one thing well one of them made many
problems are have the first watch dogs
was that the way you completed levels
was so unbelievably [ __ ] roach like
it was like dude this thing jump from
this camera to this camera and none of
it was particularly fun so i don't know
a little bit more player agency like go
a long way what do you think about it
Peter I mean like we're sort of i think
by us a little bit ly cuz it's said you
know a place i've lived for a decade
maybe it's not as important to to you
Mike mean you hate san francis yeah uh
he called it son for Romeo just go
earlier just stupid said his friend made
that you actually kick my ass after what
is going yeah what is this animosity I
say something to you today you just
review too many games are just going on
Tim excited for them to come take me so
seriously yeah it is nothing about it is
yeah it's in your hometown its origin
you're like your backyard it's fun right
yeah fun thing uh look you see this
laptop like a sticker on it that says
hacker get it immediately raises alarms
for me because it's like my own of this
game is probably gonna be [ __ ] Peter it
says hacks or oh the tone of this game I
don't know my hopes I don't have high
hopes that it's going to be able to
accomplish it you know their stated goal
of
in dealing with cultural issues in the
Bay Area which for someone who lives
here like these are things you see every
day it's not just like something you
throw you throw on because it's
fashionable to talk about like it
official people so it's the same thing
with mafia right like how how are these
games going to handle these seemingly
serious issues yeah seemingly these
serious issues I don't know I don't know
I feel like that is going to be the
bigger problem for me than the gameplay
when it comes to watch dogs yeah it's
going to be interesting mama hoping yeah
i'm sort of a little bit maybe not as
optimistic of either game doing it
necessarily but we'll have to wait and
see that's watchdogs to it's not the
last game out though there is something
about Star Park games I like to launch
some lace december six the fractured
butthole looking forward to that love it
can't wait yeah you like potholes mike i
just played a stick of truth recently
for the first time it's on say it was a
big decker yeah that's it was incredibly
funny and i'm looking forward to more
south park yeah that humor is always is
always welcome yay and that's all the
games that i have four pairs on this
this like forget anything i probably did
don't forget anything like deus ex man
kind of item excited about Toby because
i really liked human Revolution but it
definitely had problems in its structure
and how you you know you're punished it
was like the same thing with the first
dishonored your kind of punished for
going a certain route after a while and
also civilization 6 i'm really excited
about right and how they are kind of
revamping how cities work and make you
think about the map differently as a big
civilization fans 25 still one of my
favorite games six has me excited it's a
weird like I'm not someone who plays a
lot of strategy games but when he was
describing the changes to civ where it's
like all the complexities of a city
aren't encapsulated than just one part
of the grid now they're spread out to me
that sounds kind of like basic game
evolution like after it took you six
games to do this it took you decades
yeah it's it's yeah that that's was my
takeaway but I've to played it for about
an hour and it seemed there's a lot of
smaller things that aren't things you
could just like say without going to a
featureless that ranged yeah it doesn't
make you think about the map differently
because resources figure into different
city districts in a way that impacts the
overall structure yeah I completely see
what you're saying though because I was
my initial that was my initial kind of
hesitancy I mean it sounds no i'm not
saying like it makes me pass
not like interested in the game I'm like
I'm glad it's here but it's also like
her it's fine if you hate civilization
civilization 6 coming pretty soon
October 21st just I guess the same day
as battlefield one actually so you can
get over great destruction civilizations
on in many different ways and the deus
ex mankind divided much closer october
23rd so just a couple days before gears
of war oh i forgot that ok so he's in
august ok i was october i'm in august
august or cows he's held back at d'alene
ID by two months I'd no idea right yeah
so it hasn't I was lying I was deceitful
ok fri wrap this up was the one game out
of all those to you looking forward to
the most no once guy gives war or five
times 15 mafia 3 battlefield one last
guardian time for two called the
infinite warfare dishonor to watch dog
to on a guest civilization six oh yeah
deus ex wait you go first uh I go
civilization six okay Last Guardian
right I'm gonna go no man's guy and I
don't know boom watch the coast for a
while cool typical Irish sticking
together
Oh